what about
the sleep how important is sleep for
longevity
i would guess based on the evidence that
it's really important
and because we don't know for sure but
what we know from animal studies
is the following if you restrict sleep
from a rat for just two weeks it'll
develop
type 2 diabetes it's that important um
so that's the main thing what we also
know is that the molecular level
that if you disrupt your
sleep wake cycle so we actually have
proteins that go up and down that
control our sleep wake
all of us most of our cells do that if
you disrupt that you'll get premature
aging and guess what the opposite is
true that as you get older
that cycle the the amplitude becomes
diminished
and this is why it's harder to get to
sleep as you get older and then
you've got all sorts of problems and i
think what's going on is this positive
feedback loop which
is is a disaster in your old age which
is um
right you're aging you can't at this
moment
totally prevent that and then it's
disrupting your sleep and you get not
enough sleep and then that's going to
accelerate your aging process
and so it's known that that people who
are shift workers are more susceptible
to certain age-related diseases so your
bottom line you definitely want to work
on that it's one of the reasons i have
this ring on my finger which helps me
optimize my sleep and learn what i do
the day before
if it was a bad idea and i'll stop doing
that like eating a fried chicken
i see you're still carrying the burdens
of that decision
but is yeah you know sleep is one of
those things that's making
me wonder about the variability between
humans
a little bit and how science is often
focused on
like it's not often focused on high
performers in a particular way
and it's looking at the aggregate versus
the individual cases
for example like for me i don't know
what the exact hours are but
like power naps are incredible
i tend to look at the metric of stress
and happiness
and joy and try to optimize those so
decreasing stress
increasing happiness and using sleep as
just one of the tools to do that
because like hitting the five six seven
eight nine hour mark or whatever the
correct mark is
i find that to be stress inducing for me
versus
stress relieving like thinking about
that i
i feel best if i sleep sometimes for
eight hours sometimes for four hours and
then power nap
and as long as i have a stupid private
usually
smile on my face that's when i'm doing
good
as opposed to getting a perfect amount
of sleep
according to whatever the latest blog
post is
and i also pull all nighter still
i also think there's something about the
body like as long as you do it
regularly it's not as stress-inducing
like you know what
you know what it is the reason i pull
all-nighters isn't for like
i'm playing diablo 3 or something is
because i'm doing something i'm truly
passionate about well i can also love
video against but i'm doing something
i'm truly passionate about
and it's almost like there's the jocko
willing feeling of when i'm
up at 7 00 am and i haven't slept all
night and still
i'm working on it there's a kind of a
celebration of the human spirit
i really enjoy it like uh and that's
happiness
and to sort of then and i usually don't
tell that kind of stuff to people
because their first
statement will be like you should get
more sleep
it's like no i'm doing stuff i love
you should get more love in your life
bro that's right
so but that said in aggregate when you
look at the
full span of life it's probably
you should be getting a consistent
amount of sleep
and it seems like it's in that seven
eight hour range
yeah but it's similar to food it it's
the quality not
the quantity right and and when you get
it so
i look at my my data pretty often
and what makes a difference to me is not
the amount of hours but
the quality the depth and the deep sleep
is what
what'll do it so if i have a lot of
alcohol before going to sleep
and i can see my heart rate being
different but what really kills me is
that i don't get a lot of that deep
sleep and i wake up
you know barely remembering stuff so
that like you say if you're happy and
contented and you're not don't have
these
cortisol chemicals going through your
body you will more naturally get into
that deep state
and even if you just get four hours way
better than eight hours of none of that
yeah yeah that's beautiful and some of
that could be genetic for me i just
i fall asleep like this if you want me
to fall asleep right now i can do it
it's it's no um i have no problem with
it combined with coffee i just had two
energy drinks i could probably
uh sleep so that i don't know if that's
genetics or
it's kind of um i don't know what it is
or maybe that i don't have kids and i'm
single so i don't have uh
i'm almost listening to some kind of
biological signal versus
societal signal on when i'm supposed to
go to sleep so i just
go to sleep whenever i feel like going
to sleep well that's because you're
self-employed most people don't have
that luxury
but we're lucky the two of us that we
can make our own hours yeah
um but yeah it's super important and
those people who have the shift work
i mean they really need to to change the
way that works because they're
literally killing those people
you